We have seen an incredible shift where Donald
Trump has signaled that if only 200000 people
die of Corona virus in the United States,
that would be considered a very good job.
We are seeing such a goalpost move here that
it might actually trick his followers because
of how drastically the goalposts are being
moved.
I want to remind you, we have an incompetent,
failed response to the virus.
This has resulted in Trump's last tool,
so to speak, which is gaslighting his followers
so that they will hopefully forget that just
a few weeks ago, Trump was talking about.
We've got 15 cases and that number will soon
be zero.
Other countries were acting like adults.
They were preparing for the pandemic.
Here is Trump Sunday saying, you know, if
we end up with no more than 200000 people
dying.
Not cases, deaths.
OK, that would be a very good job.
And Trump sort of cleverly mentioning, you
know, one estimate said 2.2 million might
die if we can keep it to 200000 deaths.
That would be a big.
Very good job that we did not see.
You're talking about 2.2 million deaths, 2.2
million people from this.
And so if we could hold that down, as we're
saying, to 100000, it's a horrible number,
maybe even less, but two one hundred thousand.
So we have between one hundred and two hundred
thousand.
We all together have done a very good job.
But so recall that Trump tweeted on March
9th that this is nothing compared to the flu
because the flu might kill 27000 to 70000
people.
Saying, quote, So last year, 37000 Americans
died from the common flu.
It averages 27 to 70000 per year.
Nothing is shut down.
Life and the economy go on at this moment.
There are five hundred forty six confirmed
cases of coronavirus with 22 deaths.
Think about that now.
At the time, 22 deaths, now 3000 and climbing
in the United States.
And the same Trump who said this isn't as
bad as the flu.
Sometimes up to 70000 die because of the flu
each year.
Rarely.
But sometimes he's now saying if we stay below
200000 deaths, not cases, we will have done
a good job.
Remember, here was Trump saying we have 15
cases and it will soon be zero.
We've done really an extraordinary job.
When you look at a country this size with
so many people pouring in with the number
one in the world for people coming into a
country by far.
And we have a total of 15 cases.
And again, when you have 15 people and the
15 within a couple of days is going to be
down to close to zero.
That's a pretty good job we've done.
And now, if we don't lose more than hundred
thousand people, it means Trump did a very
good job.
This is a hell of a lot of deaths for something
that five weeks ago was nothing and just the
latest Democratic hoax.
So it's really, really important that we don't
take our eye off the ball.
This is a pandemic.
This is a tragedy.
At some point we will get past it.
We will have some death toll.
The latest estimates are about 83000 for this
wave.
We could then have a second wave in the fall
and another wave in 2021.
We could get to 200000 by the time it's all
said and done.
We don't know yet.
But at some point, it's going to be done.
We can't forget the incompetence and the lying
and the deception and say, hey, we made it.
Those of us that do
make it and hopefully as many of us as possible
will be in that group.
We have to remember that we've been led by
one of the worst responses in the world to
the virus.
Maybe Iran did worse.
I don't know.
China lied a lot.
Sure.
But look at how quickly South Korea developed
and deployed a test.
They had their first case on the same day
we did.
South Korea has 150 deaths total.
Not in one day total.
We have hundreds dying every day.
It appears it will soon be thousands dying
per day.
We need to ensure that there is a consequence
for Trump.
And now this framing that he's doing of, listen,
it's a big win if we keep the death toll to
200000.
He previously said we have a few cases.
It will soon be none.
We now are having potentially hundreds of
thousands
of deaths.
We can't let him get away with it.
His followers are going through.
We can't.
Enough of us have to remember that we need
a change.
In November of twenty twenty so that he cannot
get away with this.
There are medical components here.
There are social, social, cultural components
here.
Economic.
There are so many considerations.
But we've been failed by the Trump administration.
And there has to be a consequence for that.
I don't know if there will be, but I hope
there is